قال الرئيس بايدن اليوم إن
عملية الإجلاء خطيرة ولكنها
مهمة جديرة بالاهتمام ووصف فقدان 13
جنديًا أمريكيًا بأنه مأساوي ، والآن
علمنا أن فريق الأمن القومي لبايدن
قد حذره من
وقوع هجوم إرهابي آخر في كابول.  من المحتمل
أننا سنكمل المهمة
التي يواجهها الرئيس بايدن في مواجهة الأزمة الأكثر حدة في
مهمة إدارته
التي يتم تنفيذها هناك أمر خطير
،
والآن يأتي ذلك مع خسارة كبيرة في
الأفراد الأمريكيين وحقيقة أن
الأمور من المحتمل أن تزداد سوءًا ، وهذا هو
الجزء الأكثر خطورة.  من
فريق الأمن القومي للبعثة ، حذر بايدن
في جلسة إحاطة بغرفة الوضع الصباحية ،
اقتبسًا أن هجومًا إرهابيًا آخر في كابول من
المحتمل أن القادة العسكريين وصفوا
الأيام التي سبقت
الموعد النهائي للانسحاب في 31 أغسطس
بأنها أخطر فترة حتى الآن حيث جلس بايدن مع
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي نفتالي  بينيت
للاجتماع الذي تم تأجيله إلى
الجمعة بسبب الهجوم دون هوادة  إنها
مهمة جديرة بالاهتمام لأنهم يواصلون
إجلاء
الناس من تلك المنطقة
بحجم المأساة وتداعياتها التي كشف
عنها فقدان أرواحنا نحن
أفراد الخدمة الأفغان ، وهي مأساة
مروعة هي واحدة من أسوأ الأمور
إن لم يكن كذلك.  أسوأ شيء شهدناه
خلال فترة رئاسة الرئيس بايدن في المنصب ، قال
بايدن وهو يخطط للاتصال بأسر
المسؤولين الثلاثة عشر القتلى ، إن البيت الأبيض
لا يزال يركز بشكل أساسي على
مهمتين لإجلاء الأمريكيين المتبقين
والحلفاء الأفغان بحلول الموعد النهائي الذي يلوح في الأفق 31 أغسطس ،
وأعتقد أن لدينا  ينصب التركيز
الآن على فعل كل ما في وسعنا للحصول
على المواطنين الأمريكيين الباقين الذين
يريدون المغادرة خارج
البلاد والآن مطاردة أولئك الذين
ارتكبوا الهجوم لن
نسامح
ولن ننسى
أننا سنطاردك ونجعلك تدفع.
لا توجد منطقة رمادية مما يعنيه هذا التعهد ،
أعتقد أنه أوضح بالأمس
أنه لا يريدهم أن يعيشوا
على الأرض بعد الآن تتجاوز احتمالات كلاهما
يعترف المسؤولون المرنون في
الوقت الذي تواصل فيه الإدارة
التعامل مع ما يسميه المسؤولون تهديدًا حقيقيًا
وخطيرًا بمزيد من الهجمات وما زال
مئات الأمريكيين والآلاف من
الأفغان في البلاد في انتظار
الرحيل ، وهذا التهديد حاد
ومستمر
، ولا تزال قواتنا في خطر
وهم يتخذون الخطوات التي يتخذونها
لإنقاذ الأرواح وإجلاء الناس
بسبب التزامهم
بالمهمة ويؤكدون أن المهمة لا تزال
تعتمد بشكل غير عادي على طالبان
حتى في أعقاب ذلك الهجوم
حيث يعلم المسؤولون الأمريكيون أن المهاجمين
تجاوزوا طالبان.  نقاط التفتيش -
الواقع يقول مسؤولو البيت الأبيض
إنها ضرورية في هذه المرحلة الزمنية ،
فهذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة التي تمكنوا
من خلالها من إخراج أكثر من مائة ألف من الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم إلى
هذه النقطة ، وهي الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنهم
من خلالها الحصول على بقية  الأمريكيون الذين
يحاولون الوصول إلى الطائرات
والعسكريين أيضًا